[Music]
we'll the duty officer please report to
see it see
[Music]
the battle mech Patrol will be departing
in five minutes be advised to clear the
deck
[Music]
report to your stations hey hotshot hey
up here it's about time you showed up
I'm just about finished the maintenance
check hang on a second
I'll get her warmed up danger Mike
reactors coming online
not bad for 500 years old
hey yeah don't make him like this
anymore she's ready for you come on up
all hangar personnel attention
prepare for battle net departure
[Music]
reactor output is look at steady yeah
that left arm actuator is acting up
again you know the one we got in a
salvage yard and Hesperus
you've got no long-range missiles
running low on cash
yes old girl this is ready she'll ever
be
come on let's go
one more sweep and we're done with his
contract and off this rock
[Music]
Shadowhawk 7:01 we see you on the board
prepare to take control
[Music]
reactor online sensors online weapons
online all systems nominal Shadowhawk
7:01 you are clear to exit the mech bay
proceed to rendezvous and sectoral make
Oakland one warning hangar doors opening
stand clear
bass command to shadow hog 7:01 we've
lost contact with sentry post five
proceed to Charlie zero five and give me
a sitrep
[Music]
enemy detected
this is great what the hell is going on
out there
alert alert this is base command an
unidentified battle makers breach the
perimeter
all personnel prep for immediate combat
emergency crews stand by
good job 7:01 confirming kill looks like
a scout
I don't recognize the markings
we're getting reports of satellite
failures we need you back in the base
till we figure out what's going on
return to the hangar and await further
orders contact contact we have multiple
contact Shadowhawk 7:01 can you get a
visual
[ __ ] they're drilling down right on top
of us
hang on we've got a broadcaster section
patching it through attention all
mercenary units we are under attack by a
large expeditionary force I am empowered
to offer new combat contracts at premium
pay rates with substantial performance
bonuses and salvage rights are you wait
your
look at it this way kid we just got a
pay race
[Music]
you